>> YEAH.
>> GOOD JOB.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Sean: LAWRENCE IS JUST
GREAT PAIRED SPECIAL
CORRESPONDENT IN HERE WITH
REACTION FROM A MEDIA REPORTER
FOR "THE HILL," HOST ON WOR, MY
AFFILIATE FROM A GREAT STATION
IN NEW YORK CITY, JOE CONCHA
APPEARED AT OF COURSE,
JOURNALIST, FORMER 60 MINUTES
CORRESPONDENT, THEY ARE LOGAN.
THANK YOU BOTH.
LATER, WE WILL BEGIN WITH YOU.
LOOK AT YOUR REACTION, THIS IS
INTERESTING, I THINK PEOPLE GET
IT.
I THINK DEMOCRATS DON'T GET IT,
WE WILL SEE MORE OVERREACH, MORE
INVESTIGATIONS, AND OF COURSE,
MORE SOCIALISM, WHICH WILL
DESTROY THE COUNTRY.
YOUR REACTION TO ALL OF THIS?
>> MY FIRST REACTION, SEAN, AS A
JOURNALIST, SPECULATION IS NOT
WHAT I DO.
RIGHT?
I PREFER TO FOCUS ON WHAT I DO
KNOW, AND I'M ALWAYS VERY
CONSCIOUS OF WHAT I DON'T KNOW.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU JUST A SIMPLE
EXAMPLE.
IN SOME OF THE COVERAGE, I THINK
DEMONSTRATES WHERE THE MEDIA'S
CULPABLE.
FOR EXAMPLE.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT ALL OF THE
HEADLINES THE MEDIA FRENZY
AROUND PRESIDENT TRUMP
SUPPOSEDLY LEAKING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO RUSSIANS AT A
MEETING IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
RIGHT?
EXCEPT THAT NO REPORTER ACTUALLY
APPEARED TO LOOK AT WHAT THE LAW
SAYS ABOUT CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
NOT JUST THIS PRESIDENT, BUT
EVERY SINGLE PRESIDENT.
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF UNDER
U.S. LAW IS THE ONLY SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS ACTIVE
SPEAKING ABOUT SOMETHING IS AN
ACTIVE DECLASSIFICATION.
SEE YOU TALK TO ANYONE IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY KNOWS THE
LAW OR ANYONE ELSE WHO KNOWS THE
LAWS ON CLASSIFIED INFORMATION,
THEY WILL TELL YOU IT IS NOT
POSSIBLE FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
LEAK.
BUT THAT WAS USED BY THE MEDIA
AND RIGHT ACROSS THE SPECTRUM
FROM EVERY REPUTABLE NEWSPAPER
AND OUTLET IN THIS COUNTRY WAS
HOT AND HEAVY ON THE PRESIDENT
LEAKING CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
TO THE RUSSIANS AS FURTHER
EVIDENCE THAT HE WAS SOMEHOW
SOME KIND OF TRAITOR AND RUSSIAN
AGENT.
TO ME, THE MOST BASIC
JOURNALISM, IT ONLY TAKES A
COUPLE MINUTES, TO LOOK ONLINE
AND SEE WHAT THE LAW ACTUALLY
SAYS ABOUT THIS, AND DO SOME
HONEST REPORTING.
AND I THINK FOR THAT, IT IS A
DERELICTION OF OUR DUTY AS
REPORTERS.
>> Sean: JOE CONCHA, YOU DO
THIS FOR A LIVE IN, YOU ANALYZE
THIS.
DO THEY EVER RECOVER?
THIS HAS BEEN TWO YEARS OF NEVER
ENDING, NONSTOP LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
FRANKLY, THEY OUGHT TO BE
APOLOGIZING AND EMBARRASSED.
THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
>> SEAN, I THINK WE GOT A
SNAPSHOT JUST BASED ON RATINGS
AREN'T EVERYTHING, CLEARLY, BUT
LAST NIGHT, MONDAY NIGHT, THE
FACT THAT YOU, MORE THAN
QUADRUPLED YOUR COMPETITION ON
CNN, TUCKER CARLSON, AS WELL,
AND WRITE DOWN THE LINE.
THE FACT YOU ARE GETTING MORE
THAN 4 MILLION VIEWERS AND CNN
COULDN'T EVEN BREAK 915,000, I
THINK AD MAY BE A PREVIEW OF
THINGS TO COME.
THEY HAVE BEEN PROMISING -- NOT
ALL, BUT MANY PEOPLE ON THOSE
NETWORKS, CNN, MSNBC, PROMISING
A CERTAIN OUTCOME, OR AT LEAST
STRONGLY HINTING TOWARDS IT,
SPECULATING ABOUT IT, WHICH DOES
NOTHING FOR THE EYES AND MIND,
BY THE WAY, FOR TWO YEARS --
>> Sean: WEIGHT.
WITH THE FIRST THING THEY CAN
DO?
OVERPROMISE AND UNDER DELIVER.
THEY HAVE BEEN ENSURING THEIR
AUDIENCE, .
>> RIGHT, AND IT WAS TIME TO
CASH THE CHECK, AND THE CHECK
WASN'T CASHED, AND NOW THERE IS
DISAPPOINTMENT.
MAYBE SOME PEOPLE, MORE PEOPLE
THAN USUAL, WERE TURNING OUT
LAST NIGHT.
LET'S THINK ABOUT THIS PLACE I
CAN COME IN TERMS OF MUELLER AND
THAT INVESTIGATION WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, THEY HARDLY, BY
ALL ACCOUNTS, LEAK ANYTHING.
THINK ABOUT IT, THE PUSHBACK I
SAW IT TODAY WAS THAT WE HAD TO
PURSUE THE INVESTIGATION ON THE
FACTS, BUT AROUND COLLUSION, IF
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL ISN'T
LEAKING, THEREFORE THIS ONLY
LEADS TO RAMPANT, RECKLESS
SPECULATION BY PEOPLE FROM
SOURCES THAT WERE PROVIDING
INFORMATION THAT WAS EITHER BAD
OR NEFARIOUS, THEY WANTED TO
BELIEVE WHAT THEY WERE BEING
FED.
IF THERE ARE NO FACTS OUT THERE
AROUND COLLUSION BECAUSE OF NO
LEAKING, THAT IS THE ONLY THING
THAT COULD'VE HAPPENED.
BAD SPECULATION THAT LED TO ALL
OF THIS MISTRUST OF THAT WE ARE